[Music]
now you had a bet about the box office
on 21 Jumpstreet
care to discuss that bet I'm gonna let
him take this for me all right all right
so in a in a in a movie opening weekend
if your movie breaks 30 million you've
had a very very good weekend
Jonah thinks or thought that it was
gonna just break 30 and I thought that
it was going to break 35 and he said if
it breaks 35 then I will kiss the tip of
your
over the bump over the boxer's I said
over the boxer's what point is the
boxers would remain you got to be very
clear in it the boxers would remain on
say that's a key piece of fabric for the
story actually the actually the real key
is that I won that bet so yeah yeah so
worth hasn't happened yet I've given him
the opportunity to double down on it but
he just my gambling career has come to
an abrupt end I lost the weirdest stakes
yeah this very weird steak that's the
stakes and every single one right right
and if you lost you just wouldn't get
your penis kiss